виробництво нових санкцій Я все ще
переконаний, що запровадження
економічних санкцій, а також персоналізованих
санкцій після анексії Криму
та після війни на Донбасі є
цілком правильним. Я вважаю, що ті європейці,
які постійно сумніваються в санкціях,
ідею санкцій я вважаю  вони
безвідповідальні, тому що на те, що сталося в
Україні, неможливо відповісти по
відношенню до Росії як завжди. Я відмовляюся від будь-якої
ідеї щодо військового вирішення проблеми в Україні.
Я бачу право України
захищати себе та свою
територію, а Європейський Союз має
захищати Україну  оскільки це має захистити
власні цінності, тому дипломатичне рішення
завжди добре, але необхідно, щоб
Європейський Союз щодо Росії для
дипломатичного вирішення зміцнив свою
дипломатію на основі санкцій, і
для наступного раунду, я думаю, безсумнівно
, буде продовження
санкцій  для України легко сказати
тому війна не така груба, як у жорстоку,
як до Хв  sk угоди, але вони
тривають, тому ми не досягли того, чого
хотіли досягти, занадто багато людей все
ще гинуть на сході України, і
цього не сталося б, якби Росія
припинила підтримку тамтешніх найманців
, тому санкції чогось досягли,
але недостатньо санкцій і
ніколи не працюють негайно, але нам потрібно,
щоб вони досягли, безумовно, вони потрібні, щоб
досягти
наших цілей щодо Сирії, тому я вважаю, що
зіткнення з новою військовою ескалацією та
вихід Росії з дипломатичних
угод означає, що ми повинні бути більш
відвертими, і якщо ми говоримо про нереальне
це означає, що якщо ми скасуємо не потік,
ми скасуємо імпорт російського газу,
ми також скасуємо тут державні
надходження в Росії, їм потрібні наші
гроші на російський газ, щоб заправити їхню
військову техніку, і скоротити це
дуже важливо, щоб переосмислити нашу енергетику
стосунки з Росією це має
бути основою наших рішень, якщо Росія
не припинить цю нову агресивну
стратегію. Росія і я думаю, що для
Європейці також для німців легко
визнати, що всі ми хочемо
мати добрі стосунки з Росією, ми хочемо
підтримувати дипломатичні рішення не лише
для України, а й для Сирії, і
потрібен час, щоб визнати, що
інша сторона використовує це  відкритість
для пошуку військового рішення, але принаймні
після Алеппо я думаю, що абсолютно
ясно, що зараз пріоритетом у
стратегії Кремля є військове
рішення